[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm linked and
I'm Rhett joining us a day at the round
table of dim lighting our Barry Taylor
and Ben ebrill two of the four founding
members of sorted food one of the most
popular cooking shows on the youtubes
with over 1 million subscribers
ok now cooking shows they're more
popular than ever but what sets sort of
food apart is not only they are friends
healthy but it's the way that they
interact with their fans they create
more than just videos teaching people
how to cook recipes they tap into their
fan base to create a social media
platform dedicated to cooking sharing
recipes sending photos
suggesting things for them to make you
like taking photos of your food or your
beyond that every once in a while I'm
tempted to do I feel of self conscious
but I still do it self conscious but I
think this conversation is like a shame
yeah unabashedly the message behind sort
of food is that quote food brings people
together end quote
unfortunately we were not able to bring
all of the sorted food members together
today
Jamie Spafford and Mike huddle Stone two
other members
two of the other four family members
weren't in LA this time but we had a
great time sitting down with Barry and
Ben Ben is the resident chef of the crew
the only professional chef so we talked
with them about what it's like to have
the one guy who really knows what it's
like you know all about food and then
the three guys that are part of the
scenery about it but there's an
interesting dynamic and it's also really
rooted in the fact that they've known
each other not quite as long as we've
known each other but for a very very
long time since they were kids I went to
college together we're gonna talk about
how they came up with the idea for sort
of food is great great story we also
talked about their lost in hungry world
tour just kicked it off here in Los
Angeles pretty cool idea I love the
ideas that these guys come up with we
talked some about what goes into that
too but this idea is them literally
travelling around the world and only
going to places to eat that their fans
recommend or because we did open this up
to mythical beasts we will reveal where
you challenge them to go
speaking of tour in the world we want to
thank our sponsor that helps make ear
biscuits possible EF college break the
travel experts EF college break create
amazing
affordable travel experiences all over
the world for people aged 18 to 28
college not required
everybody knows the hardest part about
traveling is planning reserving flights
and hotels figuring out what to do when
to do it how to get from place to place
who to blame when it doesn't become as
fun as you hoped it would be because
you're I don't know someone you don't
like planned it dealing with cancel
reduce planet yourself poorly and you
didn't hate yourself all it takes is one
thing to go wrong the entire trip can
fall apart and you hate yourself or the
person who planned it why take that risk
when you can let the travel pros at EF
College break do all this for you and
you're not going to be mad at them
because they know what they're doing
you'll be left to just enjoy the trip
and say this way and when we said travel
experiences all over the world we was
not lying
they built trips across six continents
that's almost all of them including a
euro trip from London to Lisbon I don't
even know what Lisbon is but if I were
to sign up for this I would you know say
it's a hard candy that old men give out
the kids that's where there's original
you not as a dancer Lisbon they got a
great Aussie grand tour of Italy two
weeks exploring the islands of Thailand
and one of the best things is that they
provide a tour director who's a local
expert so you have a unique perspective
throughout your travel he's the guy that
you buying yeah if he if he messes up
you can blame him but you know what
based on everything that we know he is
not gonna mess up he or she is not gonna
mess up and even if you sign up by
yourself you won't be alone EF College
Break groups you with other travelers
you'll get to share this amazing
experience with so do it head over to
our special URL EF College break.com
slash rhett and Link we'll hook you up
with an extra hundred dollars off that's
right for a hundred hours off go to EF
college break comm slash rhett and Link
and now onto the biscuit
so how long have you guys been in LA
this this time three hours oh really
so I flew in from Seattle this lunchtime
because I've been running this whole
kind of lost and hungry tour on my own
for a week up in Portland Hood River
Seattle Mike's been making its way to
Austin and could you've come together
back here for this okay so you kind of
let you sort of tag-teaming in a little
bit so it isn't like everybody has to be
together on the last and huh not to work
we kind of work together in kind of
waves I guess we've got the last two
weeks we'll all together and then the
past week well Jamie has a baby it had
to fly back to and the UK to mother
responsibilities and the rest of us then
had to continue we've lost and hungry in
their own way
now I mean I'm such a big fan of you
guys I was telling rep because you guys
you you approached your YouTube channel
in your brand presence it's not just
okay we're we're a cooking show but it's
you guys approach everything with such
professionalism and with kind of this
network mentality that then in terms of
how you do it everything you you
approach with okay we got this new
interesting series that people can get
behind and this is just another example
in my mind so just kind of give us the
spiel of like how you came up with this
what was the motivation and then how are
you executing this this road trip thing
yeah so I'm sort of in general it's we
started really as a we've known each
other like you guys since first grade
you guys need a room yeah major 12 is it
ish oh like age six a six yes we've been
since age 12
all four of you yeah yeah yeah 16 odd
years now yeah and a long time and we em
when we all finish school we went our
separate ways University and then kind
of came back and bonded around food and
then starting making videos was
something that we all just wanted to all
fans of YouTube anyway and it was just a
natural place for us to upload the
videos to share what we were doing the
rest of the world and as time has gone
by we've we've always pushed ourselves
to see what types of content we can
create
right interests around food we want to
make food as fun others cuz there's lots
of people making food stuff I mean it's
all over television there's whole
networks is more of it multiple how many
networks food networks are they're just
floating out there these days they all
have one kind of thing in common and
that's where kind of all decisions have
already been made and the point where
they're publishing it it's kind of like
decision made
normally one share for one person to
travel the country experiencing food
there's it's kind of the only opinion
that matters them and the production
team behind them whereas the approach
we've taken the last couple of years
resources everything's kind of been
crowd-sourced if I'm honest I ran out of
recipes about two three years ago right
but actually the whole community are
always chipping in on suggesting what's
cook next and how to cook it certain
tips and tricks and how to do it so that
was kind of what this tour was all about
was going we've got this huge audience
community of people who are loving food
talking to us on a daily basis the
mountain food how do we maximize that
and let them shine and showcase what
they know in the best way in was getting
out of the four wall studio in London
them coming to first stop America and
then on to the rest of the world to
experience food firsthand with with them
in control so they tell you what what
you eat and you're saying you can't eat
anything unless they tell you to eat it
yeah two very simple we all know that's
not true but it is true so started so in
basically the only two rules one of them
is we will get kicked out the country in
90 days time because that's when our
visa runs out right we're on day 26 at
the moment I think and and the only
other always literally everything we eat
has to be recommended by somebody and
that has skewed slightly over time
there's been some great I've been
trapping alone recently a lot of the
suggestions are coming in on YouTube on
twitter with the hash tag but also every
time you get somewhere you meet somebody
who wants to share their story or their
favorite food food is something just
connects everyone you can go anywhere
and as soon as you explain what you're
doing the first thing I want to do is
tell you their favorite restaurant or
their favorite farm and producer or or
my mum makes the best version of this or
whatever see so is that what they're
doing you find it more often than not
that fans ask you to eat at places that
they
like or places that because I know that
you know we just got our fans to suggest
where you should eat before you left Los
Angeles and of course they gave you a
place that is service rattlesnake and
prawn that's because they know the kind
of things that we eat yeah but you're
getting actually good suggestions it's
not like a dare to like get stuff down
it's a completely make something depends
who who they're trying to make suffer I
guess if it's if it's been it's gonna be
some some amazing food to him to try on
the way if it's any one of the three of
us they're gonna make yourself or
somehow so it's a complete mixing so how
have you suffered so far actually so far
it's been to be so good so far I came
over to the to the states with we've
been here before so we've been to LA New
York on sort of with sort of before and
in my closed-minded view la was
California in California was LA and
there were kind of exchangeable yeah and
then we spent a week in LA doing some
great suggestions around here then we
spent best part of a week driving from
LA up to San Francisco California one
phenomenal through vineyards mountains
hills savanna Beach Coast you name it
yeah that that road had it and all the
food source we stopped on the way and
that was when I saw you begin to realize
how awesome the food in this part of all
it actually is
we've had some dead ends though when
people kind of gone what's the most
popular isn't always necessarily the
best food around
so we came in the first week when the
top recommendation of Scott Ross goes
well I mean so many people say oh yeah
Roscoe's chicken and waffles yeah
that sounds incredible but then he gave
then ego theory makes a lot of sense but
it wasn't the best chicken the water was
working was was dry mmm Oh which one did
you get
which which combo did you get mama okay
at the obama obama which is a two
chicken thighs it's good enough for your
president but it's not good enough it's
two chicken thighs and two waffles or it
was it two chicken thighs on or a noir
but as you got an omelet with the
chicken inside of it awful yeah well
nothing's bad
what you got to do at Roscoe's next time
you go now that because I person this
man next time
I've heard this this this thing from a
number of people okay is there like the
waffles are nothing great and the
chicken was dry I so I'm not I don't
have a whole lot of sensitivity to dry
meat because I'm a white meat guy but
what I do at Roscoe's is I take the
waffle and I take the chicken and I take
the hot sauce and the syrup and the
butter and I make a sandwich so you got
syrup and butter on that to kind of
moisten it up you got the chicken then
you got the hot sauce that they got
right there at the table and you make
that a little Sam I'll do a little of
that too and then I throw their cheese
eggs on the side they've got this like
diced onion in it oh it's so good man my
I take my whole family my kids but going
to Roscoe's they're like Sunday lunch
after church crowd in the downtown and
that is gonna be doing Rhetta bull scene
we have to go three o'clock women
dressed to the nines with the big purple
hats we felt very underdressed in
t-shirt shorts oh yeah that's quite an
atmosphere but you you set yourself
apart from network program and because
you're so interactive I mean every step
of this trip is is determined by
interactions but there's also a lot of
food shows just floating around on
YouTube that are like YouTube first kind
of thing so you they're also your
competition I mean how do you how you
look at that and how do you how does
that inform your strategy
are they competition though I'm serious
I don't know because they same of them
you could say in one breath you got you
jamie oliver's the world who are what we
grew up and we aspire to be like and
then suddenly he's on the platform that
we kind of grow up growing up on yeah
and do each other you know and people
are saying Jamie Oliver is no
competition you go it's a great it's a
great I'm just I'm also with fans of all
cooking shows and YouTube so we are
watching food on beyond belief as well
in your desk and so you take inspiration
from that the way that the way they
produce their stuff at the same time you
never
competition because I don't think that's
kind of what you do there but you but
you have to be informed by your friends
making cooking shows or other other
YouTube creators because you I mean I
have to assume you guys are still you
you got to do something different you
got to do your own thing right so you're
informed by it
yeah and you're always looking for the
next new thing but this it feels like
there's plenty of space for food because
food is so subjective yeah so we've got
you know and a phenomenal audience who
love different parts of what we do
and that's why we try and do a little
bit of something for everyone from an
eye candy series which is just like food
porn it's just food photography really a
motion picture all set to music know how
to's we do recipe how to's to teach you
the basics on how to make whatever it is
you want to make we do things like this
time around about exploring food at the
source and uncovering that research
there is something for everyone
so we look around all the other
competition university-commerce and see
what everyone else is doing but on the
whole we just go with what we're told to
do we do we do for a little bit
sometimes but we the same as you guys
the extent is our USP is our story it's
we're not hmm that's what I said I says
you apart from the fine brothers as well
as your stories your background and the
same of us no one no one can do what we
do because no one's lived our lives well
in you know you guys it isn't just about
a show I think that's one of the things
that that I notice is you guys have this
enterprise mentality that this is a we
are sorted food and you're gonna get not
just one show that we're gonna do every
single week that people might get mad if
we change it up but now we're gonna do
this tour we're gonna figure out what
the best burger in America is or the
world or whatever the scale for that was
and where did that mentality come from I
think it's about what we've we realized
early on that food will never go viral
food and firewood should never go
together anyway it's sticky
food is sticky not viral that's what we
got and so we've never had a viral video
ever right
the closest we got was a up-down dunk
video parody of Bruno Mars song if
donuts with donuts at the same time it's
it's we've really struggled to make that
so we have always had to push ourselves
to work out other ways of spreading what
which ones are doing and representing
social cooking which is what we're about
in different ways and also we know that
food as a topic is you mean social when
you say social cooking you mean like for
parties basically bringing people
together sounds really really kind of
Bittle aimed at the same time it's what
we always say that food isn't the point
of what we do just it's the heart
everything we do because it's what
brings us not to give us why we did the
German first place so we do that for
everything well some of the most
interesting things that are happening in
the food world it's like a touch point
for me are these are apps that bring
communities together like I you know
I've got the young Lea app on my phone
what does that do it basically takes
into account all your preferences you
put in your preferences or dietary
restrictions at the beginning when you
sign up but in your age you put in you
know all these different things and it
sort of learned you and begins
suggesting these recipes that people
have submitted and the places from
online and then also got the delectable
wine app which is like when you when you
try a wine you take a picture you just
take a picture of the label and then you
you give it a rating and so then you've
got like the professionals and you've
got the amateurs like giving their wine
tasting notes and stuff like that and
it's in but it links directly to their
their feed which is like a Twitter feed
and things like that like it seems like
you guys were ahead of the curve on that
because you kind of recognize that
everybody has an opinion about food
everybody has an experience with food
and you guys are like connecting the
dots and your that's that's what I see
when I look at sort of food I see
somebody who's connecting those dots and
connecting people yeah I think
everything when you talk to someone
about food everyone wants to share their
food experiences and often that's down
to one of two things are the pride
because it's something they're so
passionate about and they want to share
with somebody else and make sure
somebody else has experienced or it's
kind of a bit of showing off look what I
can do look at how amazing this food
photography is of my dish and whether
it's pride or showing off we were
getting hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds if not thousands of stuff sent
our way whether it was full-blown
recipes
email to us or photos on Facebook and
stuff tagged into Instagram and it was
it was kind of all over and people
suggesting things we could change up and
it was kind of like we was almost too
much so for us it's kind of building the
platform such a platform it and people
could have their own profiles perform
their own identity identity around food
and it could all go into one place that
made sense rather than all this
desperate kind of information that no
one else could access we could see it
because we've got access to our email
account but nobody else could see how
I'm sort of awesome some of the recipes
that were coming in from all over the
world so it organizes it publicly now
we're talking about your app right not
your website or is it both
yeah so the moment we're running the
website you know the platform which
enables you to set up your own profile
and have your own identity around food
and share your recipes or just engage
with other people's and then we're also
sort of running the blog at the moment
on a day-by-day basis just to keep up
with the tour because there's so much
stuff different happening with us and
hungry there's so much information
that's the best place for that so the
two are sort of running side by side at
the moment now here's an app idea so
we've we've we've been working on it for
awhile which basically allows people to
upload their recipes and so on so people
are starting to track what they're
eating what's going in their body
well you can't a secret idea and of
course with the launch of the Apple
watch and all this smart device now you
know where you can now track how you're
burning off this food yeah yeah yeah but
nobody gets delivered developed an app
yet that tracks what what you may
excrete but why because because remember
I had the idea for sorting on a pub
Taylor yeah table after a few pints that
was quite good one doctor and tells us
that you can pretty much diagnose
anything anything and you know yeah yeah
you can tease right yeah totally
it's the sign of health and vitality is
a proper poop yep so therefore you
surely must be an app out there shortly
coming out you poop on the watch maybe
leaving the toilet and you stick that
you stick the wash down towards the into
the fumes yeah yeah I mean if the watch
is on your wrist to track movement
surely whatever device you have it needs
to be near the movement down there
- Rick what's though just just leave
something in the toilet for you to
urinate the app or spider ring oh you
already have the name yes the name I
know you our own - may rename it I don't
think this is a rude word here it's not
in UK it's gonna be called the piss
taker yeah because it takes a piss I got
it did you pee on you have a device
there you go you put in the toilet let
you pee on and that then sends the
signal to your watch off well I was
thinking just poop what he got to do
with it well whatever you is crazy but
green you could start a new brand if you
wanted to go to poo Direction crapple
the crap was like a family board game
hey kids let's play crap it's a drink
over there huh so I think one of the
things too is you know a lot of people
struggle how do I turn what I'm doing on
YouTube into a business because unless
you just have a lot of content with a
lot of eyeballs on it the Adsense money
doesn't really support a business have
you guys leveraged this and you know
you've got a successful business at this
point that's supporting you guys and
employees how's that happening thing is
if you tell you to try and give somebody
advice now it's very different from what
it was four years ago we started we
their own reason we kind of manage to
exist in mobilize this is a piece of
family and friends business we when we
started playing on the idea Oh actually
been to my dad and said you might help
us out to publish your own book he said
yeah we start a few copies you guys
there's something in this and back to us
a little bit would gave us a bit of cash
to kind of allow us to start up a
channel so from day one it's always been
a family-owned business which sets us
apart from other people we've never had
a major investment from anybody the
company is completely 100% ours and
YouTube is the the numbers muted never
necessary paid for all the bills at all
we've always relied on bringing the
sponsorship we've got a fantastic
partnership we've kenwood this applies
at all the em kitchenware stuff that's
what keeps it going we sell books and
bibs in the background but you
we've never we've never been making lots
of money it's always just about
investing it back into the company
working at how we can create the biggest
and best community possible and there's
no aspirations to try to turn this into
a TV show it's just what are the
aspirations it's strange because like
several years ago I'd say yes probably
like three or four years ago we were
sort of hunting down the perfect TV I
did for a format or something whereas
and time and time again we were told by
commissioning editors or whatever that
it wasn't quite right or wasn't gonna
fit in the box they needed to take and
we'd never quite happen mm-hmm as a
result we just said well it's a great
idea we can don't YouTube anyway because
the community will have it our audience
will love it we're just going to fly it
so we did a lot of that and now it's
almost come full circle that in the last
year we have had TV ideas almost pitch
to us but they're not being quite right
and again we've always held off and just
said we're only going to make content if
it's the right content and the kind of
stuff that we know our audience will
love the great thing about this tour is
we're kind of getting a little bit best
of both worlds because by doing this
loss and hungry at all which we're doing
completely off our own back just for
YouTube we're also doing in partnership
with this is a shame yeah I saw that
you're on The Today Show and Matt Lauer
and Carson Daly are like we're sending
these guys around the konschak country
the crunchy country finish the country
they just take you how we pronounce
things we keep getting tacos and oh yeah
we saw that he was like could you say
TAC oh one more time for me so did you
approach them or did they approach you
how to network and we'd be on the show a
few times the past biggest and best
thing I've loved about this TV show
collaboration is we are still making all
the videos ourselves it's our own team
there's still only what eight of us on
the roads producing this completely and
we haven't changed anything from what we
do on YouTube for TV so when we started
the whole thing was all about how can we
aspire to TV how can we create content
as good as and one day maybe beyond it
and suddenly now things come full circle
where we are producing content the way
we always have been for last 3-4 years
and it's now good enough for TV because
it's TVs adapted yeah so that's been
that's been a revelation for us and the
collaboration there we know this this
scale of what TV can bring us and we
want to be
we won this we won sorted the brand and
the community to get as big as possible
the next couple years so TVs an obvious
way to go in the flavors at the end of
the day show seem to make a lot of sense
well let's figure out let's ship from
business to personal a little bit I'd
love to hear it kind of take us back
through this story of if you're talking
like 12 years old I didn't know you guys
went back that far so take us back there
where were you and what was up were you
like riding bikes around the same rainy
neighborhood what's up so we all went to
the same school together and therefore
we've known each other for that whole
sort of 7 7 year period in high school
or secondary school for us and various
different times we in works for town put
us part of hartfordshire
it was chosen school Chancellor school
so Barry and I were in the same before
which meant that we would be in the same
class for registration AM and PM and
occasion that be crossover with you do
sports with Mike or Jamie and I would be
doing music or I might we do music it's
like a smart kid school you said
Chancellor school I mean I know but it's
just a school ok very good school wasn't
positive at all but the weird thing was
was I I kind of got closest friends with
Jamie's things throughout school through
drama Mike through sports I didn't speak
to Ben once throughout school years even
though we share the same classroom the
whole time
he was the front of the homework and
you'd come over and write next year
students yes more say ok family members
actually for our school Ben was a
straight-a student who had massive
aspirations could have been anything you
wanted to be but you chose to become a
chef but did you know that back then
were you like I'm gonna be a chef let me
help you with your homework no I was a
lot of people were a bit confused when I
said that was what I wanted to do but I
was just wanted to follow what I enjoyed
rather than what the kind of the
railroad said that you had to do because
you were getting these great
I enjoyed math I enjoyed science I did
all of that I've got a toy chest
I still like chess - I did play chess
but that's become more of a myth
so you shot him you guys weren't even
friends because he was such an eye
geek or a nerd or what yeah yeah I feel
guilty for saying it now but no yeah
yeah we did okay again it wanted things
at fresco I did every my role in school
was to become as popular as possible I'm
shy was shallow I only did things to
impress people that's all I ever did how
did that go - not well
not well like six forms to the last
couple years of school we used to be we
were a lot closer because we were doing
more of the same subjects so Jamie Mike
and I were in the same music class for
ASU in the same drama classes and three
of them said a lot more overlap towards
our later years and we used to almost
socialize together as well didn't we
almost but but then you said you went to
different colleges yeah but but then so
what precipitated get him back together
you guys all moved back home after
college but the weird thing about our
friendship is about there's about nine
of us no overall as a forensic group and
we still meet up pretty much once a
month now all of us and we've all kind
of moved back to the same area so high
school friends a group of nine yeah okay
so by like senior year you guys were
actually friends yeah yeah okay I got it
and it's that sort of same group it's
every month don't still get together now
oh there's a whatsapp group plays pretty
buzzy in my pocket right now of everyone
continuously chatting around but it's
the same kind of as if we were on the
pub table we're still taking the mickey
out of each other continually and Ronal
off as well and even now I think that
the best thing we started this year was
the whole concept of what we are all
getting a bit older and between us
houses and kids and raves and all sorts
but we did say that we didn't want to
grow up too soon so we're now actually
every year we're doing a fake stag do so
if someone in the group is working a
fake Stang don't know you just eggs you
have Oh bachelor personal product apart
so a fake bachelor party where if a
member of the group it doesn't matter if
anybody's getting married or not if no
one they should get married then we
still need to find an excuse to go away
for a long weekend and just do the thing
that we've always done growing up so we
took a top hundred quid in a pot and say
and well whoever becomes YC cold by the
end of the trip
King stack or mistake whoever was the
pillar man of the match from trip before
then base T decides on the next entire
trip okay and that's why right up to the
point of turning up to the airport and
being handed your boarding pass we've
got no idea where we go oh really it's
like a we know because it's the group of
Fringe you do so where have you where
have you gone we've done one so far then
you started last year we went to find
Haven where is that damn so you took a
road okay that was a short a short
flight and along weekend drinking and
exploring the city how big is was your
friendship group after school was just
you two it's a good question because we
we had a we had a friendship group that
was it might have been nine or ten I
think there was a girl thank God 13 or
14 if you include the girls cuz it was
about half guys half girls from high
school that then we got together a few
times while we were in college but we
don't really there's kind of people that
if we saw them we would immediately
catch up with but we haven't made nobody
really has made a set the people who are
still back in North Carolina had made
much of an effort to like stay together
I think it could have happened but I
mean neither of us are kind of the ones
to kind of initiate or not good long
distance friends yeah we're not if link
and I were on opposite sides of the
country we wouldn't talk to each other
but they the kind of friends that you
don't have to see them for an entire
year but when you do it's like there's
been no time it's like you was like it
was yesterday
not anymore sadly because I think it's
just been - no I mean it's been like 10
years now but there was like the first
few years out of these our high school
friends first few years out of college
they were still like that kind of get
together every Christmas thing but then
it slowly faded away so it's not
happening anymore
get what you do I think some of them
they well they think they're kids do
they do now I think they do now because
we end up talking about things that they
remember enough oh we talked about them
and they'll come out of the woodwork
when we talk about our ex-girlfriends
and yeah there's a number of there's
some ex-girlfriends in that group and
Leslie's mom called me on the television
is our first girlfriend she was my first
girlfriend and his first girlfriend a
different
yeah so a month ago kay calls me and
she's like I meant so-and-so in the post
office where I saw so-and-so in the post
office and her son is a big fan and
wants a signed poster and like you know
so we were like sending him something so
it was like oh we finally finally made
it big in Lillington took that Leslie
but you know the interesting thing is
your opportunity with both of us
actually it was an in seventh grade
first rate for us it was a foregone
conclusion that we were going to end up
doing something together even when we
were 12 we were doing weird stuff like
making blood oaths saying that we were
gonna do something creative together it
did you guys talk about things like that
like we're gonna we're gonna do
something together you know let's not do
something regular chat with Jamie when
in end of the school year always going
we don't know what we're gonna do in
terms of our own careers high school of
gosh
sorry high school okay yeah we just said
to each other in the day we want to make
a difference have an impact on someone's
life I wanted it he was the one to do
marketing and I want to go into design
and the point of it was exactly the same
maybe that if they're picking something
up off the shelf
that I've designed or they've seen an
advert that Jamie's done you've impacted
someone's life somehow no matter how
small it was that's all we bonded I was
a desk
if we could work anything that Tyler
thing there so we could we could see
what we could form a into and so then
how did it happen if it wasn't like a
you know a collusion of well it was
around round a pub table a table
probably no bigger than this at the
Admiral Byng and like in name-drop it
was a um a pub in our local town we used
to go to it was the first pub you go to
when you were old enough to drink and we
all went there our pubs over there like
gift shops and museums here it's like
you're forced to walk through them
everywhere because that's what you guys
make it sound like you can't not walk
into a pub over there there's a certain
magnetism yeah I get drawn towards like
I grew up in a village which had 500
people in the village and there was one
corner shop and three pubs really yeah
but
pubs in churches yeah yeah and I guess
isn't that the definition of like a
hamlet which is like a small village as
it has to have a pub I think in a
village and be a village if it has a
church and then a town and a city oh
really it has a cathedral so that I
think that was part of the definition so
what was the conversation like literally
just scribbling down recipes on the back
of beer mats sharing that because I was
trained to be a chef and these guys were
eating sort of rubbish and kind of trash
really so we would share recipes and
although I was laughed at at the time
eventually they sort of caught on and
then some on the fact that when you're
out other than cooking for a date of
some sort and then you're in you're in
the supermarket and you go what do I do
now and then you start thinking of a
text been asked been again for some help
I was like a personal chef so when you
six or seven of you yeah when you
realize that your friends right there's
one of those moments and all of us we're
doing independent each other so when we
met up it was always clang so what did
you cook them on and so on and then in
terms of actually kind of getting
something started all we did was we saw
we had something going on we were all
studying things that we could apply to
work together e1 so there was work as a
chef James doing marketing Mike was
currently working at the school that we
went to as a sound technician
sound an IT technician and I was doing
freelance photography and wanted to get
into film at some point and then we were
selected something we can all work on
together and that's kind of we said we
did as a hobby as a way of boosting Rosi
these two start off with really to
create something we made a book did I
write what's a CV curriculum vitae B tie
the thing boost your on CV when you when
you apply for a job like a midi-chlorian
we were all studying stuff but wouldn't
it be cool if you could for us so
graduate with the qualification and an
extra thing and that thing for us would
have in a self-published cookbook
because it'd have been a record of a
load of my recipes and record whoever
your photography InDesign Jamie's kind
of marks in England how he could push
him from all the pieces were kind of
like do that so it was the book first
not the YouTube yeah
the channel book came a good year before
that and then we had up as Barry said
with some help to get a load printed
self-published and then we had a
shitload of them and we saw worked out
what we love doing which is showing
recipes on a bigger scale and video is
the obvious one because you can get the
brain ship across much better in a video
than you can on the written page so then
how did you how was that transition a
guy who had made good grades and could
do a number of different things I mean
why food I just always came from quite a
food your background my parents although
never trained or qualified in food but
they've always been quite food we've I
don't think up until the age of eighteen
I never had a ready meal as such I mean
fish fingers maybe was me like a glass
fast food meal like a meal in that you
reheat at home right takeout yes but not
not in terms of buying of a meal off of
a supermarket shelf yeah everything was
cook from scratch right and every night
and there was always great food in the
house so I just always was surrounded by
food and loved it and I've always wanted
to carry that on and therefore was so
confused when these guys so I didn't
know how to do it because it was almost
second nature to me I'd always been
around food and what kind of things were
you making for yourself as a college
student
very nice beans on toast with cheese on
top maybe a poached egg
beans on toast with cheese on top yeah
tuna surprise okay which was probably
not Gina but still a surprise yep do you
have Hamburger Helper over there yeah
we've got rustlers rustlers which you
thinking the bookies you get microwave
for burgers this is this is a packaged
it comes in a cardboard and it's like
pasta and seasoning and you're supposed
to you know take ground beef and cook it
you your own ground beef you cook it and
then you add these ingredients together
so you end up with sort of this like
hamburger pasta pastas skillet beef
stroganoff kind of like it's all these
different flavors and what we would do
is so badly we would take one of these
and we would divide it between the four
of us the two of us and then Greg and
Tim are roommates because it would
literally be you would make a pan
and so it you know would all be there
you'd I never made it because I don't
make stuff but you know like you were
Greg would yeah or Tim would sizzle up
the burger and then you pour in the
pasta and you pour in the like that
stuff looks like the stuff you get like
seasoning you get taco seasoning packet
and you just mix it all together and
then you it kind of hardens what depends
on which one you have some stay like
kind of loose and then yet but there was
one called it was like called skillet
sensation or something like that that
would make basically a big high of
burger and pasta and stuff and then you
would cut it into fourths and we would
this is really not enough for a person
to eat really obviously a college boy
but we would do this because we were so
cheap because that meal was probably
like a dollar a piece we ate that so
often and that was the limit of what we
were cooking except when we would do the
deep fryer with french fries with ranch
dressing bacon and cheese on top of them
Greg's idea to buy a deep fryer yeah and
and then retz on board with that I mean
I just
I'll just they make it I'll just sit
down and eat whatever it is because I'm
happy with cereal right exactly and ice
cream and so I was just like we were
starving college students but we weren't
willing to spend money so like we could
each of eaten one of those Hamburger
Helper things yeah but we sat there and
we would like meticulously divided up
into force and that's all you got yeah
Mike why don't we just make two I don't
know cuz we didn't have one pan yeah but
by the way we didn't have a bin we
didn't have somebody who was attempting
to rise above so you know I think we
waited til we got married but I think
that's what kind of kick-started this we
realized that it wasn't just us that
kind of were in that same situation we
just wanted more more people so i've
always compared them going from a very
sort of sheffy point of view there are
chefs out there who make careers of
having signature recipes and if you ask
them what the secret recipe is they're
saying sure they'll never ever share it
whereas I've been completely opposite if
there's something I know but that works
I want everyone else to try it and I
want everyone else to experience what I
love about it
I think that's just the whole sharing
mentality and that's where video and
YouTube and everything plays our social
media yes right then because it's it's
very natural to share I mean use the
analogy of them food photography and you
would never
nowaday you're taking it 10 years ago
you would never sit down at the table
get out your camera take a photo of it
take it down to the shots get it
developed knowing your back stick it an
envelope post it to a friend and send it
to say this is what you say yeah that's
a little involved and yet now instagrams
doing that in seconds it's that the
sharing mentality around food and food
is the most shared thing on Instagram
right now and not even what it tastes
just what it tastes like what it looks
like becomes because that's the only
thing you can really share everyone can
connect with that yeah you can just put
like a plot up mm-hmm
oh yeah exactly right that's why it
everybody does underneath so you started
to experience arted to experience Ben's
influence you're kind of going to him
and asking him for tips and that kind of
and then you guys realize that you've
got these different pieces that come
together the book happens then the
YouTube thing happens
how has the way that you see food and
how when you feel about your
relationship with food change because of
this influence in which now that it's
your life yeah I guess before sorta
didn't really think twice about food it
was just there you know I don't know
guys I think in university sorting
photography freelance and I was living
at home so Mama's always just delivering
me food every every day I mean when I
moved out then South having to apply the
recipes that we've been creating
together and testing them okay right the
bit that made me kick for me was as soon
as you found yourself not following a
recipe and we started just playing and
use it I still go once a week now I'll
cook goodie for therapy just sit there
and you just I enjoy it and I have no
idea what I'm looking to make apart from
I've got some stuff in the cupboard I've
bought some inquiries that I like the
look of let's see what happens that saw
a sense of freedom and playfulness and
then when you see the look on someone's
face when she's giving it to them as
well okay you know what I haven't done
badly here it's worth going to give it a
go again that that sense of enjoyment of
cooking into socializing that was what
kind of made it more exciting for me to
interrupts you just start caring more
and then
from that my girlfriend now she's
obsessed with organic foods and healthy
eating and understanding exactly where
food a source suddenly I'm now caring
about that as well I never thought twice
about it but I think that's just kind of
we're very much other generation that
naive generation about food and as time
to move forward now with YouTube and
social media there's less and less walls
to hide behind them so people are just
finding their stuff themselves and I do
find it it's it's fascinating well one
of the things that we Lincoln I've been
talking about is how when you start
getting older your next meal is
something you really put you really look
forward to it you know it's not I'm not
not to say that our lives are boring by
any means but I don't know something
about getting older and you start kind
of appreciating certain things and you
can plan a whole week around that trip
to that that certain restaurant that
meal that you're gonna have and I mean
that's whereas when I think back to what
we were doing in college and the the way
we were eating and the way we were
thinking about food I remember when I
took my wife out the first date I ever
like took her on I took her out to
Outback Steakhouse and I thought that I
was killing it I was like she's gonna be
so impressed because I took her to the
Outback and it's like I think about the
now I'm like I'm a little embarrassed
and I was like what did what did you
think and she can I came from a family
where they actually ate well and her mom
was an incredible cook and I was just
like what did you think she said well I
thought it was a little bit lame but I
really liked you whereas I'm like now of
course I would take you to someplace
that was like a special place that had
some character that you know but I took
her to a chain restaurant I remember
back then I made up my mind
we probably having a conversation about
this you know because I've been doing
Chrissy for a while you've been dating
Jesse for a while I think maybe you were
coming realization for what you're just
talking about
so one Valentine's Day I was like I'm
gonna I'm gonna yeah Rhett right I'm
gonna take Kristi to a place for
Valentine's Day that's like not a chain
and I found this place like using the
Yelp of the time which was like City
search or some City search yeah and
I go to this restaurant it was I can't
remember it was called you'll remember
but I show up there made reservations
and said give me a nice romantic table
and sit down there and I had to drive
almost two hours to get to this place
what never been there it was in Durham
but it took like almost two hours to get
there and then Christian I was sitting
there she's like impressed and
everything's going well and then after
being there for like 20 minutes I look
over and Retin Jesse walked in the
restaurant oh it was Valentine's you
made reservations at the same place what
is the name of that place Aragon or
perizaad perizaad perizaad and same guy
kinda George with George's garage and
Durham Ollie also kinda took the wind
out of my sails it like I'd done
something really special independently
that we just happen to show up is the
same boy yeah he didn't tell me to come
here correct cheap and do a little bit
but one of the things that you start
thinking about too and want to get you
guys perspective on this is like you can
food can serve a number of purposes and
one of them is to comfort you a lot of
people just stop there right it's just
like food comforts me and so I'm gonna
eat exactly what my mouth wants but then
there's this sort of more foodie more
Anthony Bourdain mentality which is like
food challenges you and I think that's
something that how does that phenomenon
kind of enter into your philosophy and
what you guys do it's interesting you
mention I people dying because I love
the guy and a red cup of his books and
in fact one of his books a cook's tour
was him trying to experience the best
meal ever and it was more about the mean
experience whether it was a meal cooked
in the middle of the Western Sahara
Desert surrounded by the camel caravan
that got him there and he was a goat or
whatever and he said eventually off this
huge journey across the world the best
meal ever was one they had in Vietnam
and that was what kind of inspired me to
go to meet an arm and loss last year and
it's trying experience Vietnamese
culture and food but the one thing that
food does is formal identity and connect
people it's probably the only you can go
anywhere in the world and whether you
speak the same language or not the
chances are you'll be able to
communicate through music and food
whether you speak the same language or
not and that's math more difficult let's
sit down and
some algebra brother if you take an
abacus with you you can probably get
across the basis yeah but food and music
both of them you can form an identity
around and both them you can communicate
people I think that's where fundamental
you go right back to basics and it's
just kind of that's why everyone gets it
right in those other cultures I think
that's one of the things too is that
those other cultures foods are
challenging to you know appalling people
get grossed out by and you gotta be
careful their food is it's a delicacy in
one place I had do you ever have the
fermented herring yeah strumming yes
that's the one
and it is expensive so when you are
offered some you don't want to sort of
turn it down or spit it back out but it
was revolting no the smell yeah the
beauty he opened we start something had
gone wrong and it exploded and it was
the worst smell I've ever smelled in my
life and we all course this is a bad
batch but it was it was perfect it was
told us it was pervy I wouldn't believe
it
it's literally fizzy on your tongue as
you eat it it's just but it's somebody's
delicacy and therefore you've kind of
got to respect that without you'd have
an opinion on food and stuff but you
could be careful not to write so well
it's interesting because when you talk
about the challenge of kind of expanding
your horizons it's it's kind of a
microcosm of kind of appreciating
another culture yeah but I think you're
even thinking about bringing that
mentality into just your own way of life
you're like not being a picky eater I
don't know I don't know if you're
cutting your eyes at me here but no but
I mean you've changed significantly in
the past 20 years of what you are
interested in eating oh yeah you know I
have a natural disposition which is I
dislike stuff new stuff you like new
experiences so I like the same year a
lot of different things and I enjoy one
night I'll be like this is the best meal
I've ever had then the next time like
this is the best mode ever had I'll go
to a new city and I'll be like I want to
live here then next week I want to live
here it's justice my disposition is just
to want the next thing but I mean you
there's there's a hundred things that
you wouldn't eat when you were 20 years
old that you lean now oh yeah I mean I
wouldn't
I wouldn't drink milk or water I would
only drink soft drinks until I was like
out of high school and but I've actually
started to crave sushi over the past
four months like that's my new thing I'm
finally able to get there well sometimes
there's this little thing that just
clicks with were the food right but I
want to explore how when you got a
YouTube audience you've got typically a
younger audience and those people tend
to be picky ER you know cuz your palate
hasn't matured yet so how does that
enter into the way that you guys present
your content and what specifically you
talk about the food that you're
introducing people into how do you kind
of take in that take into account the
internet fickleness those people have
makes a massive difference we know that
if we want to get a viral video around
food you're gonna do something that is
cupcakes cupcake multicolored
multicolored cupcakes rainbow views yeah
but we know that every time we do
anything that is curry based so heavily
spiced or alcoholic or anything that
like you said a more mature palette the
views never seem to deliver on it but we
know it means when you then we do meet
ups do you mean the community they're
the things that are cooking every day
other stuff that you guys do made your
what someone was just example Goan fish
curry mm-hmm the thumbnail of it is
awful it's very Brown doesn't look very
sexy it's not a sexy title to a video
everything days would is destined to
fail on YouTube but their mouths do you
me who said I made that recipe and it
was brilliant I use it every way can you
go okay that's complete different from
how many views or how many comments you
get so then how do you how does that
impact your approach then I think we've
always said that food we we are we try
and do something for everyone so we we
always have a balance we'll try and do
food from as many different cultures
around the world there's many different
ingredients and styles and stuff so that
we have ticked every box that let's go
back to the thing that's sorted we try
and get a problem we try and give a
problem a solution we try and get it
sorted and we kind of won there any
point if anybody was to come to the
channel
and was looking for something they have
a problem they're looking for a
particular dish or a particular scenario
we hope there'll be a couple of options
there that will get them sorted so
they've got choice and we always try and
tick every box but we also know that if
you do sweet stuff and baking and and
homemade bread and things like that then
they are more popular so you kind of
pepper that in a little bit but if you
could make the decision you could just
say let's just you know what let's only
greenlight things that are those big
view getters the things that people want
to see and why not do that yes mmm
I think we run like most challenging
YouTube Peter because most of our views
come from a backlog catalog I think
people know people discover us from our
new videos that go up that are more
viral suited and but once they really
want to stop cooking they look for our
back - Oh completely yeah it's always a
surprise you do a meet-up and you're
then you're chatting to people and the
the integrity of the meter isn't just
about meeting people grabbing a selfie
and moving on everyone there it wants to
show you what they've cooked or which
recipes have cooked or tell you their
favorite dish and everybody is different
there's not ten recipes that keep coming
up as everyone's favorite we've got 700
recipes and every time you do a meet-up
it's different people cooking different
dishes and that's what spurs on to keep
doing different stuff because it's the
variety that keeps it and the integrity
we go back to where it all started it's
not about fast food and and baking and
cakes and sweets and stuff it's about a
balanced diet and things you can cook
quickly and cheaply at home on a day to
day basis so we always try and keep that
sort of integrity through what we do as
well as we all want to make a cronut
video or whatever but right it's the
best of both worlds what do you think
about people who don't care about food
it's just not their thing
food not my thing man and I think
personally myself and Mike probably can
empathizing the most Mike still is
doesn't really care that my sometimes he
he M he's Mike Alessi has been working
on unsorted for the last five years and
he still can't cut the onion because he
his brain doesn't need it none of us
myself Jamie and Mike we don't aspire to
become incredible chefs we just we use
it like anybody else we want to enjoy
the food and I think we always
we them we've got a couple of friends
from school who we didn't listen to get
along with and who are we always say
they're the hardest cookies to crack
there are people we if we can appeal to
mm-hmm
certain characters yeah Martian odd
trying to hide the name there's a
character that we could use as an
example if we can appeal to your calling
and Martian five and what who couldn't
and who doesn't who doesn't care at all
about food literally hates this stuff
and also finds us a little bit annoying
how can we stay okay yeah like what we
do what's the answer
into food for us the moment that's why
we have so many series as time goes by
keep mixer Hill with different ups of
people and you're right I think I'm on
YouTube if they don't like us we have a
bit of a problem but then saying that we
have an incredible community all critten
different of the food and on an app now
we have people who have bigger profiles
than us hmm
so who are creating their own types of
food so you should hire this well I'm
curious about the dynamic amongst the
four of you then if I mean if if there's
only one chef and the other three of you
don't aspire to become chefs and one of
you doesn't even aspire to cut an onion
interpersonally how does that work on a
team I mean you guys is there is there
conflict is there kind of a okay you got
a guy who knows his stuff and how am i
valuable kind of thing is how do i
insecurities play out I think right back
at the stop right so you can't answer
this you're the one who's got it all
together honestly I think my dad's
didn't everyday there's any reason that
we work as a friendship group is because
we are so hot in each other we are it
works in most our entire friends and we
I come the last time I gave better
compliment and any of us anybody
compliment we always should give a down
so therefore the no egos ever allowed to
grow out of this at all but we all
respect each other massively though what
we will be good at and what we do so but
if it's about food and you've got a chef
but that's what it I really think that
you can't answer you know it's also any
Black's over the first time we wrote the
first cookbook and I would write down
recipes and the whole point was that
that recipe was only 70% there because
it then had to go through the sense
check because I was writing it as a chef
it needs to be dumbed down and
demystified and actually was when the
other side is down yeah yeah that was a
statement of superiority see that that
right there is where the conflict comes
from I'm anticipating this but to mass
market rather than people who aspire to
be chefs or translate it and excuse that
make it relatable relatable that's a
better relatable and accessible it's a
better word and but when he says
something like ok dumbed down my recipe
for the masses or for you guys do are
their fights or their arguments camera
we give Ben a seriously hard time there
is no other cooking because you're
inferior to him I mean is that because
you don't know the food there's that
that's kind of the foil it has to be a
part of it every other cooking show out
there
the chef is the man you don't mess where
is where the only channel out there who
puts him up and then knocks him back
down undermine and belittle completely
otherwise you're just been preached to
but but I'm not I'm not cooking a plate
of food for somebody just to eat we're
doing you for a YouTube channel to share
yeah right so the skill sets in say
Barry
initially photography in graphic design
and stuff like that I mean we've had I
say arguments we've bickered over the
fact that I've wanted to plate it this
way a plate of food because that's how
if you're in a restaurant that's how I'd
want it plate it he said it doesn't look
good on camera that's not how we're
doing it really even though it's like
we're using each other skill sets to and
mike is the absolute best at just
cutting through all the waffle going but
you just need to break it down I'm a
novice I need to know this I don't need
to know that bit I need to know this bit
right even though you represent he
represents the audience yeah and I
having this sort of a lot scientific
background but liking the science behind
food and understanding how the food gets
that point that's the bit that I always
want to to push into it and then you've
got the sort of the creative flair the
other side you need to balance of all of
it because without it no one would work
and are there
was there a point where you guys divided
up workload
and what your roles were and I'm even
curious yeah it's like okay you bring
the recipes you bring the script so to
speak but there's a there's still a
question of is there a question of well
is everybody pulling their weight kind
of a thing you know even amongst the two
of us retina I still have conversations
about strength and different strengths
and playing to our strengths and giving
each other room
to do things maybe if I've got an
insecurity about something and I
overcompensate like well you have to
have these conversations I'm curious if
you guys do yeah all the time we we
recently have a chat with between the
four of us about we for every video to
go out all of us had to sign it off and
have a look at it and the system was a
bit too kind of confusing at times
because they're almost too many opinions
on every single video and we said look
Jamie you're the man to look at every
single thing that comes through and
you're the person sign off because he
will respect everyone's opinion the best
Jamie's Jamie's Jamie's the people
person Jamie can we say he's a king of
emails because he would never not
respond to an email and he's always he's
always the person who is made he's there
to make people happy
it's an obsession yeah so there for him
is in that role that's almost channel
manager really well well for Jamie and
Mike is everything content now Mike had
no background in production at all but
it's only since kind of working and
producing the videos he's almost become
the voice of sorta to an extent he knows
the tone that we need to kind of be
putting forward in every single video he
works with a couple of editors now
freelancers and Louise who's off of her
production who just basically puts every
single video together now and been
looked at and and looked after
everything through they've got James who
is a he's our social media guru and but
also as a trained chef where the scene
universe has been and I'm the one who
tries to work out what I'm doing most of
the time so does everybody else
but we kind of I think we talk very
openly amongst a group about what we're
doing are we doing it right and we're
very open to shoot ourselves down and
say
doing right will change it it's YouTube
no I went none of us set the rules none
of us looking for promotion here in a
job so therefore we've all got
everything to gain but also everything
to lose if we're not careful so we have
to work as a team essentially because it
really is the dynamic of like a touring
band in a lot of sense that I would
imagine you know you're like the
Arrowsmith of one direction of cooking
whoa I gotta say cuz they're breaking up
let's talk about them at length now
that's not then is there funny that I
said Aerosmith put that on the back of
your DVD let me further date buzzer why
don't you put up put my quote on the
back of your cassette tape link said we
were the Aerosmith of I don't know why
you have a cassette tape so is there a
you know we talked about the fact that
we've got this mentality this that we we
do not see nor really do have
aspirations to go off and try things on
our own we're just like well as long as
we're around we're gonna be doing things
together is it like okay guys sorted
food this is the thing or is it like
none of then you want to go and be a
head chef at a restaurant one day you
know like what is the mentality and do
you guys talk about that yeah I think we
will basically need we will know that
what we're doing now is the best thing
we can do right now and yet so when I
grew up when I was trained to be a chef
all I ever wanted to do was aspire to be
a head chef in a gastropub somewhere
creating menus on a regular basis
serving maybe 50 60 people a night
because I didn't know this existed like
what we're doing now we've kind of
forged our own way that the way the sort
of a a YouTube production company which
didn't really exist five seven years ago
when we were so University or whatever
and we didn't even know that existed and
yet now we're coming up with recipes on
a daily basis with the community so I've
got like a million development chefs
working with me to create the best
recipes and we're sharing them with
hundreds of thousands of people a day
not 60 in a restaurant so we are
literally you're I am personally living
the best job ever but that doesn't mean
that occasion you look out and see what
other stuff people
doing and you need to get that
experience to make sure you so you're
leaving competition so so I've had that
in my notice and I can't imagine do
anything different like we've been doing
it for five years now and it's not a job
because you never switch it off it's not
a nine-to-five it's you live and breathe
it yes it's what we are I don't think
any of us really sign up to this that's
all I think I I know I think you had
some aspirations of becoming Factory and
a TV chef I guess but none of us really
wanted to be on the screen cat oh it
just seemed to be what was natural and
thank Bears right I don't think any of
us we know what's around the corner I'd
love to say the sorts of community well
one day outgrow us and become its own
entity and had there'll be more than
just the four of us to represent sort
it'll be number of different chefs well
you got a Brazilian spin-off already
yeah congratulations on that thank you
terrifying to me that came from that Lee
the exact same thing you started going
we are food never be viral it's growing
at a good pace in english-speaking
countries and but we know that YouTube
and the food culture in Brazil and also
Japan is is thriving so we thought
actually we can open a sorted section in
in Brazil and see how that goes and ask
some of our friends as they would you
mind running a channel under this sort
of food brand with the same ethos the
same you know same community see how
they go at the moments going down really
well but yeah I think really great it's
been really weird to see everything
we've worked on suddenly working so
easily somebody else thing about this
different series and stuff like that the
fact that it's the fridge cam concept is
so formattable as it were something that
somebody else can grab and as long as
they have the same attitude towards food
and that's well that's all sorted really
is it's an attitude towards food and
it's not about we went from meal and
more in LA couple weeks ago suggestion
it was the second highest rated thing we
had to check out one LA and that was
Korean barbecue mm-hmm and we went for
Korean barbecue and he just sat around
the table with a little sort of grill in
the middle and just picking up food and
chatting away you think that is kind of
that epitome of what sort of it is
social food yeah food
to be there as the glue but it's more
about the people you're with and the
conversation and the fact that you can
pick up something like fridge cam and
send it to another language in the other
side of the world and the attitude and
approach to food is the same that's when
it was kind of like the penny drops I
actually this is well you know III think
in this conversation I've been a little
challenged you know the fact that you
know i-i've kind of it's been a bit of
mine to be and I don't make anything I
only make cereal because it's true
i scoop peanut butter and I pour milk
over cereal but you know I mean for so
what would you say to a guy like me or
just me cuz I'm here right and what's
your challenge for me what's your
challenge for Rhett and Rhett you can
kind of give your your cooking profile
that's mine so my I think I can
empathize in extent because I felt
growing up through which is to fuel was
well they're running faster and being
fit or anything else and then I got lazy
and I just kind of stuck to what I knew
and it was just the comfort things go in
the last couple years through sorted
I've treated food as a fuel again but in
a sense of I know that I have to be
working at my best at all times and with
what we've been there we would push
ourselves stupidly hard and I've cracked
a few times so on life is pretty simple
we have to get rise sleep well exercise
and eat well as well and surround
yourself by good people the food bit was
something that I was let myself down
with an exercise as soon as I started to
to look after my body and go I try all
different types of food and if things
like any to see how it affected me as a
person and how I didn't have to take any
kind of extra nutrition or drugs in the
morn to get myself driving if I just err
well by Sun City for juice in the
morning and got my that was like taking
a drug for me suddenly I was so much
more energy I didn't have to eat as much
carbs and then I go actually what was I
started eating more and more sushi and
more fish and actually I was even
sharper in evenings any might die off
and I might try something else but I end
up the best thing I did was test myself
on different foods and see how my body
my head everything else reacted often
suffer yet and that for me was something
I just found really fascinating I never
seen so food is such a important part
your the way you work
so lay into me just let me have it
what's the challenge try something new I
think it is that it's they pushing the
boundary to try something new now I've
started trying stuff and once once when
I haven't start I think that I think my
main challenge from you guys at this
point is that I don't I'm not willing to
make anything like I'll try it if
somebody else that will give it to me I
think you can retake you try something
so but cooking it preparing it but but
take away so that is the essence of
cooking being the chore part of it if
you make that the fun part the plate of
food happens to be the result but
actually the fun part and the part that
is more we back in the day we used to
always go away in the summer and camp
down in Bournemouth where Jamie and
studied and we used to do big group
barbecues and stuff and it was all about
sort of making the food together and ash
the fact we had a big laugh I have food
at the end was kind of irrelevant it was
actually bout the main process and the
process it was more fun and he got the
beers open you're drinking and
socializing playing games or whatever
but it's actually the make the process
of it it's more fun so all I would say
it is make that process as accessible
and fun as possible get the kids
involved
oh yeah what sneaking what's the barrier
because wait that's the thing make it I
just I relate to that because I'm no I'm
no great cook but I love to cook and I
have so much fun doing it like even when
my my wife is like I'm just gonna leave
you alone and let you do this thing I
just like it there's like three or four
things going at the same time I'm just I
have a blast and like you said once it's
once that's the the meals there half the
time when you've made it you're kind of
like I you guys can enjoy this I'm I
enjoy food better when somebody else has
made it for me you know but it's like I
had so much fun sitting there drinking a
glass of wine while importing a little
bit in there I was making it you know
that kind of thing so what for you link
what is the barrier is it like I don't
know that I could do it or I don't want
to spend the time to do it like what it
when your wife leaves you alone takes
the kids about in North Carolina or
whatever and you know you have like a
week alone like Christy tells me she's
like he'll just eat peanut butter and
ice cream and cereal and he'll go like
to
but he won't we will not make himself
anything it's like when my wife goes
away I'm like what am I gonna make
myself that I don't have to force her to
eat yeah well let me answer it this way
I'll reflect upon it meantime I'll thank
you guys for coming in here and create
sorting out this your biscuit and next
time you guys come link what I prepared
a meal for you there was our ear biscuit
with sorted food berry and Ben let him
know what you think about this air
biscuit hashtag your biscuits too what
their Twitter is at sorted food just
like it sounds I'm not gonna spell it
cuz you already know I also leave a
review on iTunes cuz that's helpful
alright so I left us hanging at the end
of this thing did I did I didn't mean to
make it a teaser like oh I got some like
introspected though I just want to end
the podcast with them like talking so
much about myself but it was you know
wanted to gather my thoughts it was a
little weird I'm just gonna be honest
with you it was a little weird to me
because I was like okay
weird we had this really good
conversation going about food and then
like we're like this this is a
challenging conversation and then you're
like I don't know I I don't like to cook
I mean I don't cook for myself and then
I'm like why and you're like I don't
know I'll reflect on it like a bad
childhood memory like you won't the one
time you tried to cook a grilled cheese
somebody came in poured hot oil on your
face or something like what what is the
is there a story the story is I was
trying desperately to in the episode
because it's Christie's birthday dinner
and I had a date with her and I I should
have just said hey guys it was really it
was very abrupt it was it was it was
like it was as if I had struck a nerve I
was like whoa
something one thing I don't know about
Lincoln's made it awkward he's a has an
emotionally-charged reason why he
doesn't cook which I know you well
enough to know that you don't have an
emotionally-charged reason for anything
it's like I know that's not what it is
well that and that's
was ironically it was I was taking my
wife out to dinner and I didn't want to
be late I should have just said that but
instead I made an awkward ending I
reflect on that but in fairness will
reflect on it don't you cook I felt like
if I answer the question honestly it
would have been another 15 minutes
but now that I've reflected on it maybe
it'll just be another one and a half
minute that's what it should be I think
the simple fact of the matter is I have
so many control issues that play into
cleanliness that every aspect of cooking
for me is it's like a potential mess
it's a burden of the additional cleanup
and I've never seen it as a creative
process or an outlet I've always seen it
as something that will have to be undone
and I I admit that's wrong you did you
know encouraged me maybe I can change I
feel like I should turn over a new leaf
I'm open to that well I mean I think the
best way to overcome this is approach it
from something else like what else do
you do in life that you enjoy that you
have to be has to be cleaned up after
you know you can if you can latch onto
that Wow then maybe you'll be into
cooking I'm good at that
well that's a good point and I will I'll
look at it that way from now on okay
good we are cured you is it a disease I
think so I think not cooking as a
disease and but you don't cook a lot but
you do it as a creative outlet that's
what you said right right you get
excited I'm definitely not good at it
but I love doing it and every once
awhile I create something I'm like man
that's I give that to another human it's
funny that you say you do it when your
family's out of town
and but I didn't quite understand that I
wanted to unpack that for a second I
mean I will cook for myself you know
when you've got kids you you can't just
give them anything that they're they're
already so picky so you got to be like
really careful about what you cook for
them so it's not the risk of someone
else pooh-poohing your recipe it's it's
practical concerns that you're not gonna
like it anyway you want to be more
adventurous it's easier when you only
have to answer to you you know and I do
I cook for my kids I mow
my wife pretty pretty regularly I mean I
don't cook as often and my wife does by
any means but you know and there's a lot
of tag-teaming that goes on it's I pitch
in and take this dish or something like
that it's it's it's it's a in the way
that I lay tional the way that I've
addressed that relationally is I'm like
baby you love to cook that's you enjoy
it so go for it and I'll be happy to to
clean up anything that you would okay so
this is crazy so you're not you're only
willing to clean up like you're like I
don't want to cook because I got to
clean up but the only way that I've been
involved in cooking in the past is
cleaning up but doing them the bad part
I'll admit then I I like clean I'll
admit that the reason that I choose not
to cook sometimes if I'm if I'm alone
and to go get something from a
restaurant or have something delivered
is the cleanup it is the bad part but
I'm saying it's worth it man I know I'm
talking out of both sides of my mouth
but I think that went and I maybe I
don't know I need can I reflect on this
yeah why don't you reflect on it some
more but I will say I think that the
active process of creating something I
have to clean up seems counter and
counterproductive but if someone else
gonna gonna do that and then I'll you
know I enjoyed it so now I'm gonna I'm
gonna clean I'm not gonna make you clean
all this up because I got to enjoy
eating it I feel like I owe at least
that much I don't know it's my mind
screwed up huh
yeah yeah you need to go see somebody
about that we just keep talking about it
yeah it does feel like we need like in a
therapeutic addendum is this combination
and you accomplish something and it's
satisfying and it tastes good when you
get done with it yeah what if it doesn't
maybe there's that fear of failure - hmm
well there's a lot going into this
mm-hmm and I was abused by food as a
child okay a grilled cheese sandwich
oh man has the music been playing a
while hopefully cuz we be out by now
okay or we are right now thank you will
be found this one you notice next week
[Music]
[Music]